welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for the final season of Star
Wars the bad batch a Ventress somehow
returned following her supposed death in
the events of the dark disciple novel
but we're going to explain who she is
and why she's back because these final
15 episodes of the bad batch are coming
in a three episode premiere starting
February 21st and we got to break down
this trailer shot by shot for all the
details that you might have missed
what's going on with ass her lightsaber
and other details you might have missed
about her and how this season will
finally answer the question of somehow
Palpatine returned but not just that
another question that not enough people
have asked about that genetic lineage
that could tie in with the upcoming Star
Wars movies The Ray movie and the thraw
movie which I think should just be
called air to the Empire right right
yeah and actually you know what let's
start with ass Ventress why not a
Ventress is of course the death muri and
former KN sister Sith assassin
Apprentice to Count Dooku and lover to
boss quinland boss of course this boss
is taken Assa created for the original
2003 Star Wars Clone Wars but later
reintroduced in the Clone Wars animated
series as Count Dooku's Apprentice but
when Darth cius got spooked by The Sith
rule of two he ordered Dooku to have
assage killed which led to assage
rejoining her night sisters of damir but
ass's life would further be explored in
the 2015 novel dark disciple which
adapted some unused arcs of the
unfinished sixth season of Clone Wars
and in dark disciple assage venturus
falls in love with Jedi quinlin Voss and
she ends the story getting Zapped by
Duku Sith lightning and clearly and
definitely dies in quinlin's arms her
body laid to rest in the waters Clan's
Village on damir now you remember
quinland Vos the obiwan Kenobi series
established that quinland Vos survived
to participa in in the path of surviving
Jedi from Order 66 and an article on
Star wars.com included a quote from
producer of bad batch Brad Ralph saying
quote we don't want to spoil anything
but want fans to know that any new
storytelling with Ventress will align
with the events of Star Wars dark
disciple so they're not Ronnie dark
disciple so huh how is Assange back well
I think she did die in the events of
dark disciple and I think she was bu on
damir changing those parts of dark
disciple would definitely be a rcon but
I do suspect this season of bad batch
will adapt some elements of dark
disciple and we might even see ass's
corpse resurrected with night sister
magic in the Ahsoka finale of course the
great mothers use the same spell to
resurrect those Storm Troopers that the
night sisters used in the Clone Wars
episode that included Assange rejoining
the night sisters in which the night
sisters battled with the forces of
General Grievous and I think this is why
it was so important for the ahoka series
to take us back to pidia and established
that the thron Allied sorceresses there
were night sisters in particular so that
way they could bring things back to
damir and find a way to resurrect
Assange and you'll notice here that
assag in this trailer carries a yellow
lightsaber that she supposedly scored on
the black market it has a curved Hilt
like the hilts of her former red Sabers
but those were taken from her when she
was ambushed by the Jedi Baris Ai and
baris's Plot to Bomb the Jedi Temple in
Clone War season 5 and frame it on
Ahsoka was the episode the wrong Jedi
assage did carry a yellow saber during
the time of dark disciple the color
yellow was important to her during that
story as for her it reflected how she
leaned neither toward the Sith nor the
Jedi historically yellow lightsabers
have been used by Jedi Temple guardians
but we will most likely see how their
meaning will evolve now that Ray carries
a yellow saber in the final shot of the
rise of Skywalker and we are confirmed
to follow her in a future film and I
only saw like quick images from
celebration but I'm pretty sure there's
going to be a yellow saber in the
acolyte but perhaps more important to a
you'll notice that she wears a blue
puldon with a coiling snake sigil this
actually comes from character art by
Chris Glenn shared in September 2014 on
the Star Wars the Clone Wars official
Facebook page and the caption of this
post says that this Twisted black snake
was quote chosen since snakes are an
often misunderstood creature that are
assumed to be dangerous or evil when in
fact they are not so it just kind of
seems like as a resurrected night sister
carrying a yellow saber assage could
really be the missing link to events
decades in the future thron's return
with the night sisters to the planet of
damir depicted in the Ahsoka finale
which could set up Ahsoka season season
2 and everything that's going on in
death Meir right now and of course in
thron's follow-up movie heir to the
Empire let's hope it's called that but
also another plot line the path of Jedi
I think that quinland Vos path could be
the same path that Ray picks back up
after the events of the rise of
Skywalker and that we could learn in the
series that that path was something that
was overseen by both Quin Lin boss and
ass Ventress still working together with
ass just resurrected with some kind of
nightsister magic I just like this idea
that the future Jedi Order could really
just be called The Path and the path
could refer to a less politically
aligned group that just kind of follows
a dogma of General Guardianship and you
know doing cool like psychometry
okay but let's talk about what happens
in this bad batch trailer this trailer
opens with an imperial lat pursuing an
A6 Juggernaut hijacked by some members
of the bad batch including Hunter and
wrecker and hold on a second I'm pretty
sure in this one shot where Hunter says
let's move that is Crosshair back there
so Crosshair escapes we know from other
parts of this trailer that Crosshair
will spend at least some time with Omega
in that mount tantis facility but I'm
hoping that Omega might finally complete
the process of showing Crosshair the
light so that our man could rejoin his
brothers after some kind of extraction
but you're probably asking why would
Crosshair be with the others but not
omega well maybe she is and these shots
just aren't showing it but I'm assuming
this episode is actually part of episode
12 late into the season that episode is
called Juggernaut and this is an A6
Juggernaut that we saw in the Battle of
kashik and Revenge of the Sith episodes
one two and three of this final season
are titled confined paths unknown and
shadows of tantis and I think this
season will begin with like a rescue
attempt from Mount tantis but that
attempt could fail and maybe only
Crosshair will get rescued and that
Omega could be left behind either by
something going wrong or maybe even by
her own choice and then we might see a
time Jump because later in this trailer
notice how omega's hair changes at some
point during the course of the season
and she looks a lot older and we keep
hearing characters saying Omega has been
trapped for a long time omega's been
waiting for us a long time and they're
implying that you know we haven't given
up on her structurally this could work
like Avengers end gamees opening act
like we get a rushed response mission
that that fails followed by a several
years later time Jump how much older
does Omega look I don't know I would say
at least a year and actually later there
is a shot of a crashed shuttle that
looks a lot like one of the shuttles
they used to escape the mount tantis
facility at least they think that's
what's happening there and one of these
shuttles gets shot down by a turbo Laser
cannon I think this could be the site
where they recover Omega to bring her
back while the others had gotten away we
do see two figures walking away from the
crash site and the one closer to the
crash ship looks like Omega but I got to
point out we do know from another shot
that Omega will join Recker as they are
pursued by Alpha 3 Nimbus class V Wings
these are the ones for the kuat
corporation precursors to Sinar Fleet
systems Tie fighters and in this shot
you can see omega's energy bow on the
left side of frame to the left of
wrecker so Omega will eventually escape
with the others I just don't know if her
escape attempt will be shortlived or it
just might come later and in this
Juggernaut Mission they are saved in
this trailer by the Genoa returning from
season 2 shooting down the latch and
clearing their six in a similar way to
Han Solo saving Luke in the last second
in the trench run in a new hope we do
see more of this Juggernaut Mission
later in the trailer when the juggernaut
blasts across this bridge we do see the
same bridge in the opening shot of the
trailer this video is sponsored by World
of Warships and perhaps I should tell
you what World of Warships is because
it's become a bit of an office obsession
over here lately World of Warships is a
free-to-play game on PC and console that
lets you take the Helm of a fleet of
ships and turn some other Fleet of ships
into ship wrecks it's crazy fun and
there's always a ton of new content to
explore new ships new in-game nations
and a ton of fun Cosmetics like Godzilla
versus Kong Transformers and Mega Death
you can play 12 versus 12 battles alone
if you'd like but it's super fun to play
in a division with your friends to get a
fleet of your own click the link in the
description to download worlds of
Warships today during registration use
the promo code Bravo to receive a huge
starter pack including 500 deons 1.5
million credits 7 Days of premium
account time and a ship next up this
ship approaches a base that's orbiting
corant but this base looks pretty
familiar it actually looks like one of
the massive Dome ships that are
stationed on loal throughout Rebels is
this the same one that Ezra Bridger will
wake up every morning glaring at or are
we going to learn that the Empire
established these kind of city-sized
inner atmosphere Landing shuttles on
strategic planets that they occupy and
another shot Rex tells Hunter I thought
that the end of the war would mean an
end to losing more of our brothers so we
got to assume that this final season of
bad batch will show us how Rex ended up
on CEOs with wolf and Gregor when we
catch up with them a few years after
this and Rebels but for Rex of course
the war will never end and even the
rebels finale epilog implies that he
fights in the Battle of Endor then
there's this weird shot of a building
that looks like one of the monasteries
of the Bomar monks of Tatooine you know
the kind that Java uses as his Palace
but this doesn't look like Tatooine
looks as though there's like a crashed
ship or a bonfire maybe a funeral P
there is this pink sky Planet later in
the trailer with similar Rocky plateaus
and then we flash back to Tech
sacrificial fall in the season 2 finale
then this Legion of Stormtroopers
marching across this yard with rows of
colorful Skiffs as civilians flee I
wonder if this might be on the planet
with the swamp Beast later in the
trailer because later we do see recer in
hun Hunter and I think that's fix Shand
on a boat that could be one of these
Skiffs but note that we are now seeing
Storm Troopers as the Empire has mostly
done away with clone troopers and their
relying on an army just normal human
volunteers and draes because you know
it's cheaper but this also means that
the bad batch are going to be way more
okay using deadly fire on them instead
of stun mode that they would use on
their fellow clone troopers after the
events of last season Omega is of course
living and working in the Imperial
facility on Mount tantis on the planet
Wayland which yes is a reference to the
Wayland utani Corporation the alien
franchise but Mount tantis was
originally a location in the thraw
Trilogy of books by Timothy Z it was a
base where thraw cloned an evil Jedi in
his campaign to subvert the new Republic
the bad batch Series has brought this
location back as the setting of The
Empire's cloning operation in the years
after the destruction of the Camino base
but while Omega was taken here I don't
know if she's necessarily a prisoner she
is wearing the same choing cloner patch
but it seems like she's like forced to
help them and do tasks to continue the
genetics research under Dr Hemlock who
is voiced by Jimmy Simpson and we
learned at the end of last season that
Dr Emory Carr is like Omega a fellow
clone sister both of them coming from
the unaltered DNA of Jango Fett in this
facility Omega passes a very very tired
looking Crosshair she did find him in
the season 2 finale in this facility in
a kind of bed scanner that looked like
the one grou was in in Chapter 3 of the
Mandalorian but yeah the two are going
to find a way to connect and we see how
important this whole cloning operation
is to Emperor Palpatine as Ian mcdad
himself appears as the emperor he's
flanked by two red Royal Guards as well
as the kamino and Nal Dr Hemlock and a
few Imperial clone commandos and he says
there is nothing of Greater importance
to secure the future of this Empire yeah
we have to assume that by the future of
this Empire he's referring to the future
of his own genetics finding their way
into a viable strand cast so that he can
be in effect Immortal and come back
somehow in the rise of Skywalker
immortality was palatine's Pursuit ever
since his time with dth plag is the wise
and it's been clear for a while now that
you know nals and Hemlock Omega and Carr
on this show are all part of the plan to
show the early steps of Palpatine's
cloting experiments to explain his
return in that episode 9 film now the
rise of Skywalker novelization goes into
more of the cloning science details but
I think the way this show will surprise
us is by establishing how within the DNA
of Palpatine's various strand casts
might be an ounce of goodness that could
come from Omega like a dormant Gene that
might make one of Palpatine strand casts
a dud but that guy could ultimately be
the father of Rey and that could justify
how Ry is who she is related to
Palpatine but also just has some great
qualities things that she gets from
Omega now there's this interesting shot
here in front of the mount tantis B
where Stormtroopers are faced by this
dark armored clone trooper I thought
this might be Crosshair but no I'm
pretty sure this is one of the Assassin
clones that we saw in season 2 episode 7
remember you're fighting the wrong
battle brother so what does that make
you a
Believer actually it could be this
character listed in the trailer's closed
caption as cx1 and we hear him say this
they are coming for all of you yeah at
one part during the sequence it looks
like this line is being spoken by a
clone so I'm assuming cx1 is a clone
assassin and I guess I'm just saying
that because we met clone X and maybe
they're just incorporating the letter X
into this one's name finck Shan returns
her helmet on the table as she takes a
drink CAD Bane enters through a doorway
blasters drawn we saw finck and Cad and
bad batch season 1 that amazing duel as
finck aided the bad batch Nal in
rescuing Omega from CAD Bane on borovo
as CAD Bane was hired by the choan Prime
Minister llas Su to find her both
characters would appear in live action
of course F Shan first in the
Mandalorian and then both of them were
in the book of Boba Fett which ended
with Boba Fett defeating CAD in a duel
but you know a light was left blinking
on his armor so who knows like if a
venturous can come back CAD Bane can
come back but that's like years from now
Hunter says this line we're not big on
following orders which has got to be a
nod to the whole plan 99 you know text
final words when have we ever followed
orders but notice in this shot the
barrel of a sniper rifle is to the left
of Hunter I assume this is Crosshair
just another piece of evidence that
Crosshair escapes Mount tantis and will
rejoin the crew just so we're clear bad
batches 15 episodes are titled confined
paths unknown shadow of tantis those
first three episodes on February 21st
then on February 8th episode 4 a
different approach March 6th episode 5
the return March 13th episode 6 and
seven infiltration and extraction both
on that day then on March 20th episode 8
bad territory March 27th episode 9 The
Harbinger April 3rd episodes 10 and 11
identity crisis in point of no return
April 10th episode 12 Juggernaut April
17th episode 13 into the breach April
24th episode 14 flash strike and then on
May the 1st the finale episode The
Cavalry has arrived May the 1st that's
just a few days before May the 4th Star
Wars day so doesn't it feel like
something big might be revealed in this
finale it could be any a number of
things some set up for Ahsoka season 2
or thrawn but I kind of feel like it's
going to be a link way into the future
to Ray and the path like they might say
that the path is really tradition
originated by ass Ventress and quinland
boss in their love for each other but I
want to know from you what do you think
the big twist of this final season of
bad batch is going to be if you haven't
already do us a fa give this video a
like And subscribe to new rock stars I'm
Eric Boss thanks for watching
bye-bye